298 cents that's how much money it
will take to buy a gallon of paint
it's friday morning and tom havens is
to buy the paint after school today
to make the purchase his father gives him a five
dollar bill a crisp new five dollar bill that he
received at the bank yesterday this particular
piece of money is just starting in circulation
what will happen to it what will it be used for
what can money be used for what is money anyway
after school the five dollar
bill goes to a hardware store
where tom uses it to buy the paint this is one
of the most common ways in which we all use money
as a medium of exchange for goods tom exchanges
a certain amount of money for a gallon of paint
the clerk naturally accepts the money and
he gives tom a smaller amount of money
in change and so the five dollar bill has found
its way into this cash register but it doesn't
stay long it's going to be used to pay mr kelly an
electrician for work he has just done in the store
the store is not paying for wire or fixtures
but for the electrician's special services
this is another use for money as
a medium of exchange for services
as well as for good the five dollar bill is
moving fast that's because it's so convenient
to use in business transactions in fact it's
hard to imagine doing business without money
yet for thousands of years people did
get along without money in primitive
days living was simple and each family produced
whatever it needed the first kind of business
was barter a good stone cutter for instance might
make a few extra tools and simply trade them for
furs and other things he wanted it was easy there
was no need for money even today barter has its
place not long ago tom havens got a spotlight
for his bike by trading a catcher's mitt for it
swapping like this works well between friends
but what would you trade in a hardware store for
a gallon of paint and how would the store owner
get the paint and the other goods he sells what
could he trade with all the people who had a hand
in transporting the goods to his store what could
he possibly swap with all the stockholders of the
hundreds of factories that produced the goods how
could he bark with every individual workman who
played a part in the manufacture of each article
no life today is too complex people are
too dependent upon each other jobs are too
highly specialized for us to do business by barter
that's why we depend on money as a quick and easy
medium of exchange thus instead of doing a certain
amount of electrical work in exchange for gasoline
mr kelly pays for the gas with yes the same five
dollar bill he received at the hardware store
this convenience of modern money has evolved from
an age-old search for a satisfactory medium of
exchange out of the simple barter of primitive
people spearheads became one of the first
articles used as money shells have also served
as money wampum was used by the american indians
and hundreds of other articles have been money
to various people at various times but none of
these met all the requirements of good money
money should be something of value yet hubert
a huntsman has any use for spearheads the value
should be obvious and uniform who but an expert
knows what this fur pelt is worth money should be
easy to carry about metal rods certainly aren't
money should be divisible how do you make change
when the price is half alcohol money should be
durable too much salt money got caught in the rain
out of such trying experiences gold and silver
emerged as the most durable most
convenient most satisfactory money
for greater convenience men started stamping out
gold and silver coins with values imprinted on
them later governments took over the exclusive
function of coining money because unscrupulous
men began to cover cheap metal disks with gold
and silver plating so today in the united states
any money is counterfeit and so worthless unless
issued by the federal government and anyone who
knowingly tries to spend counterfeit money
may be fined a large amount and sent to jail
the coins we use are made in one
of the three mints of the united
states treasury located in san
francisco denver and philadelphia
and from the bureau of engraving and
printing in washington comes our paper money
including of course the five dollar bill of this
story this represents the final stage in the
evolution of modern money for while metal coins
are handy for dealing in small amounts of money
when transactions require larger amounts
paper money is far more practical
a five dollar bill for example is much easier
to handle than say five dollars in dimes and
just imagine buying something that costs a hundred
dollars and paying for it with ten thousand cents
fixed the paper bills and even the
coins themselves they represent
face values only by huge
reserves we will continue free
a check is not money it is one kind of substitute
for money its value is guaranteed not by the
government but by the person who signs it since
the man at the filling station knows mrs moore
he is willing to take her word that she has enough
money in the bank to make the
check good so he cashes it for
saturday morning finds the five dollar bill
still in mrs moore's purse how will she use
it good morning may i help you yes can you tell
me the price of those bookends in the window
yes that pair is 875 and most attractive
i'm afraid that's more than i care to spend
do you have a cheaper pair i do have one
pair left that's an exceptional value
it's really worth 650 but it's
on sale at just five dollars
i'll take them please they're very good-looking
and certainly worth five dollars worth five
dollars yes since the value of our money is fixed
by the government we use it as a standard for
measuring other values so money is not only
a medium of exchange but also a standard of
value at one o'clock saturday afternoon the five
dollar bill is transferred from the cash register
in the gift shop to the pay envelope of virginia
hype the clerk who sold mrs moore the bookends
and when miss hype goes to spend the bill she
learns how money serves still another purpose
hello do you want to make another payment on
your radio well yes but i see the price has gone
up since i bought it well don't worry about that
you have to pay only the original price of thirty
dollars oh i'm glad you're there your balance
is just fifteen dollars i was so sure the price
when i bought it was only thirty dollars so we see
how money serves as a standard for future payments
a yardstick by which we measure the value of
anything bought or sold to be paid for in the
future but what of the five dollar bill
soon its adventures take a strange turn
this radio shop is where tom havens works after
school and on saturdays when he's finished his
work for the week he gets a five dollar bill as
we have seen it could be the same five dollar
bill his father gave him to buy the paint
and where did his father get it from the bank
and it's going back there tom deposits the
five dollar bill in his savings account
he deposits his money every week storing it up for
his future needs this way he's using money as a
storehouse of value thus our five dollar bill has
completed one round trip from the bank and back
tom first used it as a medium of exchange
for goods mr kelly received it as a medium of
exchange for services it was convenient for him to
carry around and use for any business transaction
and no one ever questioned that it was worth
five dollars because its value has been fixed
and guaranteed by the government when mrs
moore made her purchase she used money as a
standard of value and miss height found that
money is also a standard of future payments
when the bill returned to tom he used it as a
storehouse of value now it's back in the bank but
it will pass through many many more hands before
it is worn out and withdrawn from circulation
it may even go along with some world traveler who
will soon exchange it for an equal value of money
of some other nation for modern
money convenient to use easy to
recognize and universally accepted for
the value fixed by a stable government
it is money which makes possible our complex
international society of business trade and travel